I have no idea what's
about to happen at all,
but we just walked
through the public bits
of Peak Cavern,
where the tourists go.
This is Elise Freshwater-Blizzard.
Hi!
Introduce yourself, by all means.
Hi everyone on
Tom Scott's new channel.
(laughs)
It's really nice
to meet you, I'm Elise,
and today I'm taking Tom caving,
and like he says,
he has no idea what's going to happen.
You know, the safety crew know,
the camera crew know.
I have no idea what I'm
getting myself into.
I mean, yeah, that's a slide.
- Oh, yeah.
I think I might be more terrified
of the idea of claustrophobic spaces.
Genuinely, just a slide to nowhere.
(both laugh)
All right, what have I let myself in for?
Here we go.
(slide swishes)
Okay, so,
I was briefly worried.
I don't know why I was
worried about getting muddy,
given what we're about to do,
but I have,
I have no worries about that now.
That's fine.
Yeah, that's been ticked off your list,
and it's only going to
get muddier, Tom, so.
Ah, good, wonderful, wonderful(!)
Let's go.
Lead the way, lead the way.
I wish I could sound enthusiastic,
I'm just genuinely nervous.
Okay, this is fine.
This is a big open cavern.
Yeah, and if it ever does flood,
we'd know straight away
cause we'd stop being
able to hear the river
that flows below us just there.
Right.
But it's not going to flood today.
It's a brilliant nice, dry day,
so don't worry about that one, Tom.
Oh, good(!)
(water splashes)
So this floods all the way up
above our heads filling the tunnel?
Oh, absolutely, yeah.
We have a lot of indicators
before it does flood,
but it'll flood the whole system
in this room when it does.
Wow.
So, all the way up to the ceiling there,
and we measure it pretty much each time,
just out of curiosity, we want to know
just how much it takes
rain to get it to flood.
Yeah.
All right, guys.
Okay, into the water.
If it's any consolation...
Yeah?
This is really low.
Okay.
So we've actually
come on a very good day.
Cool, all right.
(both laugh)
(water splashes)
Okay, so the best way is back?
I like to place my
back against the wall,
but it is up to you.
Yeah, that makes sense,
okay, cool, yeah.
Okay.
I've got my arm out,
if you need me.
I'm good, I'm good, thank you.
Glad I've got the helmet on.
(water splashes)
Mine's filling up now.
I'm on the borderline.
Oh.
I'm close, I'm not quite there.
Oh, you can't see mine, but mine.
Ah, yeah, okay, go for it, yeah, go.
Excellent.
All right.
My wellies are filling up
at this point!
Okay, ah, okay, ah, yeah, no, that's....
Yeah, I thought I got through without
having cold water in my wellies.
Oh, no, that's wet socks, okay, lovely.
Ah, that's cold.
Ah, and that's muddy as well.
Ah, ah, ah, okay.
Ah, that's incredibly unpleasant.
Oh, that's cold!
Okay, cool.
Oh, how do you do that?
We're going to do it again.
Oh, good(!)
(laughs)
Wonderful, magical(!)
Great. Are you ready?
Yeah.
Let's go.
I hate this.
All right guys, this might
be a really good bit, too.
It's really—
I... genuinely, sorry.
I've got to tip some water
out of my boots.
That's all right.
That's actually too cold.
Woo.
SAFETY TEAM: Yeah, it's unpleasant
to begin with.
Yeah, sorry. I need to take
a second, just sit down.
'Cause that's actually
almost painfully cold.
Bloody hell!
Aw!
How do you do that?
That is freezing cold,
and it's stuck at my feet.
Whew.
(wheezes)
- Are you all right there, Tom?
- I mean I'm laughing,
but yeah, that's...
that's actually painfully
cold. That hurts.
Just take a breath.
Five minutes.
Your heat, body temperature
will warm the boots.
So after five minutes,
the water inside your boots
is going to become your
own body temperature,
and that's how we get used to it.
So the first bit is
really difficult for sure.
Yeah.
Oh, bloody hell!
That is like someone's
taken a pitcher of ice water,
which, literally like,
it is that cold,
and poured it down both my shoes.
How is it...
How are you okay with that?
Also like camera team, safety team,
how am I the only one
grumbling about that?
Whew.
Give me a sec.
Well, that's actually...
like, literally I can hear the water
coming out of the camera op's boots here,
and he's fine.
And you're fine.
I'm genuinely not.
How am I getting cold
water shock off that?
That's genuinely... I need
to properly sit down.
Yeah. Give me a minute.
That got real very quickly.
(chuckles)
Yeah, legs up.
If you can, Tom,
Yeah.
find a point
where you can prop your
legs up a little bit,
just so you can
keep your head a bit lower
in proportion to your knees,
and that will stop you
beginning to feel shock.
Yeah.
If you just, like, lean
against me a little bit more.
Yep.
Or twizzle around. Yeah.
Okay now, hang on, hang on,
hang on, hang on, hang on.
If you're able to.
Yeah.
I want to keep the water
in my boots, though,
cause otherwise I'm going to
have this again in five minutes.
Without wanting to do that.
Yeah.
If you're comfortable,
just leaning backwards.
Yeah. Okay.
I'm fine being a prop.
(laughs)
That's genuinely embarrassing.
I don't know what to do about this.
I mean, I knew we were going
outside my comfort zone,
but I did not realise my comfort zone
was like... having cold feet.
That's, that's embarrassing.
So this is not what I
expected. Thank you, Elise.
I was expecting this to happen
like a long way in, and
we'd have mild problems,
and it turns out what I've
actually had is just like...
what I assume is like, thermal...
I'm talking to my safety guy, now.
Like thermal shock response,
something like that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It affects different people differently.
Yeah.
You may find that
now you've had it,
Yeah.
the rest of it doesn't bother you.
But yeah, you're certainly
not the first person
who's found that
really unpleasantly cold.
So don't worry about it.
- Yeah.
Like, I can, don't get me wrong,
I can deal with cold feet,
but what happened though
was just sudden body nausea
and almost like my brain
starting to shut down.
It was like, stop this now,
and I am genuinely worried that
that's my body's response
to cold water on my feet?
(laughs weakly)
It's a very normal response, indeed.
Yeah.
A lot of people come in with that.
Sometimes it's physiologically
location specific, as well.
Because you're slightly out of your
comfort zone, underground.
Okay, I think I'm good to go now.
What, what happened?
Because I basically just—
You've just had
cold water shock, Tom.
Right.
And you'll be absolutely fine.
You just needed five minutes
just to reconfigure
your body there, but
you are absolutely fine.
Okay.
(Tom and Elise laugh)
That's genuinely...
Like, I knew this was going to
be outside my comfort zone,
but I did not expect just cold
freezing water on my feet,
for some reason...
Even if it's summer, right?
Yeah.
Something about that caused
my body to go into just... panic.
Mind was fine. I've been
talking through it, but body...
All right, well let's
keep going. That's fine(!)
Lead the way.
He's all right!
I kind of side step,
but you can do it
whatever way you wish.
Just kind of duck walk through here.
Yeah.
Normally the water level is
up to my waist, at this point.
Okay, I'm really, really glad we came in
on a dry day, cause this is...
Okay.
Oh, there's the rock. Yep, okay.
Found the rock.
That's the one everyone
trips over. I got it.
Why do you do this?!
That's my hand wet as well.
Okay.
All right, you've committed.
You're in the cave now.
Yeah. (laughs)
You want to take a seat?
Yep, hang on.
Oh, yeah. Oh, no.
How? Oh, my God,
it's the same reaction.
I—
That's it. Just catch your breath.
Yeah.
It's really weird doing this while
there's three cameras on me.
(laughs)
It's...
no, I'm fine.
Like, I know I'm fine, but
my body's telling me I'm not.
To be fair, that's a really
natural reaction to have.
Yeah.
You just sit through it,
and just, yeah, relax, lie down.
It's really, it's embarrassing.
It's not!
Cause there's six people in this cave,
and only one of them
is physically unable to
walk through cold water,
and has only just found this out!
I think I was fine with all this.
That bit, it's something like...
I'm glad the water's not any higher.
Yeah.
Because I think if that hit my chest,
I'd have been in trouble.
Okay.
That's....
Okay, so the good news is
I've found something out about myself!
Thank you for that.
(everyone laughs)
And thank you Pete, safety team,
for making sure I'm medically okay.
Like the good news is, I have found
something out about my body.
The bad news is, ah,
I can't do cold water.
Okay.
That's all right.
That is... that is news.
That is not something I
knew until five minutes ago.
How deep's the next bit?
How deep, do you think?
It's thigh deep.
Depends on the water level.
I won't... I'm not going to sugar coat it.
As you stand in the water,
the water level's about there.
The roof, however, is
about that much above it,
so you'll go through like this...
I can't physically do that.
So I was wondering how you might...
Yeah.
No, like, I can't.
Oh, I hate saying these words.
I can't physically do that.
- That's... it's not a problem.
So to...
all you need to do water-wise
from this point in the trip
is what you've done already.
Yeah.
Once we get to the deeper stuff,
obviously you don't
have to go any further.
Yeah.
When we get to the next wet bit,
I'm quite happy to kind of slide in first
and show you how I do it,
and then you might make your own mind,
but I understand that you
probably won't, and that's fine.
It's more that I don't
want to take the risk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like that's... and that's
a horrible thing to—
Everything I'm saying now is
against everything that I believe in.
Like I really, really want to
push myself and get in that.
Yeah, yeah.
The athletes who go into
ice baths or stuff like that,
I could have built that tolerance up?
Yeah.
But having not done anything
like that since I was a kid...
Oh, this sucks!
I am so angry with myself!
I am going to be grumpy
about this for long while.
But, however, having said that,
cavers really like a person like you,
(laughs)
because we would rather
you say what you're saying
now, than not tell anyone,
go through it, and then we have
something really difficult to deal with.
Plus, you looked badass,
and I did not!
So let's go as deep as we can.
Let's get as far as we can here,
show me what you can,
and then I'll steel myself for going back
through the other way.
Okay.
All right.
Just climb.
I swear, this is longer on the way up.
That gap is just fit for me, isn't it?
(laughs)
I can just fit in there.
Careful. Three points of contact.
Okay.
I feel almost too clean for this.
Like from the waist up, there's
not much going on there.
Waist down...
Oh, yes.
(laughs)
Oh, what? You haven't even got
anything on you.
I don't know how.
What happened?
I genuinely... apparently climbing
through mud, I can do!
That's fine.
Got no problems with mud.
You should take the camera team onwards.
So at least the audience,
you can get a couple shots
of what's beyond there.
I'll wait around with the crew.
(water splashes)
I'm just waiting in the cave now
while they've gone up there.
I hope they're having fun.
(laughs)
(water runs)
They went into waist-deep water.
I wish them best of luck with that,
and I'm going to... I'm
going to wait in the cave.
Wish you were here, Tom!
Oh, that's cold.
So how are you feeling?
I'm okay.
I'm back here.
You are back here.
It's really, really,
gutting that I can't do this.
And I genuinely... part of
my brain's now wondering
whether it was just a panic attack.
I've never had one of those in my life.
Or it might be that it's
some sort of thermal thing.
I genuinely don't know.
Yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
What's good is that you've done it,
so you can do it again.
You know for sure what's there.
Oh, yeah, I know.
Like worst case, I can
come out the other end,
and I sit down for two or three minutes
until the heart rate gets back down
and I stop feeling nauseous.
Yeah.
Who's going first this time?
Oh, well, you know what,
I think I'll go first(!)
(both laugh)
So you feel a bit more comfortable.
How about that?
All right.
Are we ready?
It's just here, where it's just like,
that is my whole lower body in the water.
This is okay. This is now fine.
Yeah?
Yeah, not a problem.
Not a problem. No problem.
I'm aware that's what I said
up until this point last time.
Mind the rocks on the floor.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, if my chest goes in now,
I'm going to have a really bad time.
So, slow and smooth,
and smooth is fast.
Last bit.
Still good.
Yeah. All right.
Great?
Yeah.
Good job, you're
committed to it now.
(both laugh)
All right, we're halfway there.
I mean, it's still unpleasant,
but there's still something
really going on
with my legs right now that
is not meant to be a thing.
So I need to take a second.
Yes.
But, breath's fine.
Stomach's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're good.
That's just, yeah.
That's okay. We're good.
Yes, excellent.
And this is the easy route?
Yes, this is the easy bit.
And it's shorter as well.
Okay.
This is it.
Thank you.
So, what have I learned?
I don't know if that was a body reaction
or a brain reaction.
I've got no idea, on the way in,
because I'm perfectly happy
to stand in this now.
So I cannot tell you if that
was my body freaking out
or if it was a panic attack,
which I've never had
in my life, but maybe,
maybe this is so strange
that I genuinely do not know.
Wow. I just gave Tom Scott
a panic attack(!)
Yeah.
(both laugh)
Or it's just such an alien thing,
and the sudden cold did
cause a physical reaction.
I couldn't tell you which that was.
I'm now perfectly comfortable
standing in this.
I think I could,
I can stay up to about here.
I think if my chest went
I'd be back in trouble,
so I'm really glad
I didn't go further.
It's gutting.
Like, it's absolutely gutting.
I'm glad you got to see it.
I'm glad the crew got to see it.
Thank you so much.
Well, as a caver,
I want to say thank you.
(laughs)
You gave it your best shot,
but not only that, you told me
when you felt uncomfortable.
And as a caver, that's just
what I really want to hear
is "I'm so uncomfortable.
I don't want to do it".
And that's what it's really important
to communicate with
each other as cavers
how you feel at all times, really.
Don't worry, I'm going
to start taking ice baths
and get my body used to this.
I want to come back
and get through that.
(laughs)
Elise, thank you so much. Let's go.
Let's get out of here.
Let's go.
(brush scrubs)
[Formatting: Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]
And I'm a bit cleaner
than when I came in.